ahora mismo en la nevada es donde se
está luchando por esos votos y es que el
voto está ahora mismo muy ajustado
bailén lleva la delantera con 49 por
ciento de los votos mientras que trump
tiene el 48% solamente les separa un
voto mientras que en arizona ha sido
también una sorpresa a este estado ha
sido tradicionalmente republicano de
hecho bueno de ahí es de donde provenía
el senador john mccain de ahora mismo
bailén lleva el 51% de los votos parece
que ella es el ganador mientras que
donald trump
tiene el 47 por ciento aunque eso sí nos
informaba en esta mañana que todavía
queda casi medio millón de votos por
contar y se espera también que vayan
llegando algunos votos por correo aunque
no se esperan tampoco grandes sorpresas
en arizona pero si estamos viendo nevada
muy de cerca porque la situación puede
cambiar de hora en hora y de hecho no
parece que la razón de que estos estados
que han sido más tradicionalmente
republicanos ahora estén votando más
demócrata podría ser el voto latino y es
que ha habido muchas movilizaciones ha
habido un gran esfuerzo
por parte de muchas de muchas
comunidades muchas organizaciones
latinas para promover el voto hispano